die angst vor der existenz ist da und
die trifft eben nicht nur kleinere
unternehmen sondern auch menschen die
wir alle kennen sie stehen sonst auf der
bühne oder sind in filme sind auch die
kunstschaffenden die jetzt betroffen
sind bei mir jetzt mir julia mir du hast
eigentlich über 300 auftritte im jahr
sollte es gerade auf tour sein jetzt
wirst du hier bei uns weilt auch du
angst um deine existenz hast richtig
also ich bin eigentlich so gut wie jeden
tag unterwegs also ich kenne die dame
gerade dieses gefühl von stillstand gar
nicht also wir sind wirklich nur
unterwegs und bis ende april sind jetzt
erstmal alle konzert also ich spiele
auch gerade eigene konzert ist ende
april ist erstmal alles gestrichen auch
in normalen auftritten und dann im mai
werden die karten neu gemischt aber man
muss sich überraschen lassen du hast
einem bewegenden instagram post auch
klar gemacht dass man jetzt vor allem in
seiner branche oft noch versucht so zu
tun als wäre trotzdem alles in ordnung
du willst genau das nicht machen du
sagst du hast angst und es ist nicht
alles in ordnung warum hat sich dafür
entschieden jetzt auch so offen damit
umzugehen dass es eben jetzt auch für
dich und deine kollegen schwierig wird
also ich bin kein fan von panikmache
also ich ziemlich auch dazu irgendwie so
auf dem teppich zu bleiben und zu sagen
es geht immer irgendwie vorwärts und
jeder glaube ich schon mal irgendwie auf
gut deutsch situationen erlebt ich auch
und man kämpft sich durch und ich bin
nicht dass man alles schwarz mal so ja
aber man kann trotzdem auch mal von
mensch zu mensch sagen weil ich bin
selbständig ich habe also mit meinem
mann zusammen
drei angestellte man hat es geld
investiert um das ganze aufzubauen
man kann trotzdem auch mal sagen okay
auch ich habe angst aber ich will
trotzdem auch mut aussprechen an die
leute da draußen die ähnlich fühlen die
glaube ich alle dieses gefühl kennen von
dem ich rede
diese unsicherheit einfach zu sagen nein
es ist
lasst euch nicht von angst und panik
leiten sondern schaut irgendwie nach
vorne und auch wenn es gerade irgendwie
total hoffnungslos erscheint aber
irgendwie
müssen wir uns irgendwie zusammen halten
wir müssen jetzt zusammenstehen
zusammenhalten aufeinander aufpassen
achtgeben leute menschen schwächeren
schützen ältere schützen
die ganzen vorne uns also die ganzen
regelungen händewaschen diskutieren und
alles was dazugehört
bis jetzt aber dran halten und darum
verstehe ich natürlich auch dass man
jetzt nicht 3000 mann vor der bühne
stehen haben sollte ja das verstehe ich
auch also das sind natürlich die
menschenmengen die du dann auch auf
mallorca dann normalerweise bei deinen
auftritten hast mallorca jetzt komplette
ausgangssperre also auch dort liegt das
leben das soziale leben momentan am
boden es gibt es einfach nicht weißt du
wie es auch anderen kollegen von dir
geht die eigentlich fast ihre ganze auf
mallorca aufgebaut haben da sollte es
jetzt eigentlich bald wieder losgehen
ja man hat immer so als mallorca
künstler dankbar immer okay ist es
betrifft in new york also an dieser
stelle auch schön gruß an die
mallorquina an alle wieder leben alle
die wir kennen und lieben haltet durch
es wesentlich besser aber wir haben halt
wirklich auch jedes wochenende
deutschland österreich schweiz luxemburg
frankreich wir sind unterwegs nicht nur
ich sondern sämtliche also die ganze
branche und bestehen alles still
wir sind alle so gebremst und wir stehen
da und sagen wann toni wieder spielen
dann können wir nie darum gehen wenn wir
jetzt angenommen sagen im mai geht's
weiter
jeder veranstalter sagt du ich muss aber
erstmal bewerben ich kann nicht einfach
aufstehen und sagen kommt rein
das ist alles so ein aufbau wo man sich
einfach gedanken macht man sich dann
auch noch zu hause und man grübelt und
denkt nach und sagt so geht das weiter
also soweit ich weiss geht es allen
kollegen von mir so die sind alle
eigentlich gut unterwegs und stillstand
danke auch für diesen einen blick noch
mal eine ganz andere richtung